Francia socialista para las elecciones
presidenciales del próximo año poco a
poco se han revelado los candidatos sin
embargo entre los franceses se mantiene
la duda si el actual mandatario Emmanuel
Macron aspirará a la reelección
no puede responder a la pregunta lo que
quiero decir es que no me encuentro en
la situación de responder la pregunta
que concierne al país y a mí al mismo
tiempo en el monte en la entrevista de
una hora y media defendió su mandato que
entre otras cosas aliviado con una serie
de retos como la pandemia de covit19
ataques extremistas y las
manifestaciones de los chalecos
amarillos
51 cigüeña bus aprendido una cosa y es
que no eres ningún cambio si no se tiene
un respeto infinito por todos y creo que
alguna de mis palabras han lastimado a
la gente creo que podemos cambiar las
cosas sin lastimar a la gente así que
eso no lo volveré a hacer es esta que
uno busque sus oponentes criticaron la
entrevista por considerarla injusta
campaña según sondeos de opinión Macron
perdería en la segunda vuelta la primera
vuelta electoral está prevista para el
mes de abril de 2022